In Britain, two Russian nationals, Ruslan Boshirov and Alexander Petrov,...
...are charged in the March poisoning of former Russian spy Sergei Skripal...
...and his daughter with a Soviet-era military nerve agent, Novichok.
Authorities in Japan now say 11 people are dead and hundreds more injured...
...due to Typhoon Jebi, which disrupted land and air travel...
...and left thousands of passengers stranded at a major airport.
In Syria, children in eastern Ghouta are returning to school for the first time...
...since Syria regained control of the area.
More than four million students are expected to attend school throughout the country.
In Pakistan, US Secretary of State Mike Pompeo...
...met leaders of Pakistan's newly elected government in Islamabad...
...to shore up bilateral relations.
Finally from Peru, Chilean couple Rosario Maduena Atalaya and Jorge Tovar...
...are arrested for alleged human trafficking...
...after attempting to leave the country with two babies.